[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde sur vos chaînes
locales de la tnt et sur lcp qui nous
accueillent tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité
avec elle à une l'appel aux dons de le
fs selon l'établissement français du
sang le stock de produits sanguins se
situe en dessous du seuil de sécurité
les besoins sont urgents heureusement à
saint-etienne et d'honneurs sous-tend
rendez-vous vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage à suivre de tl7 la télévision
de la loire
déployés partout en france depuis un peu
plus d'un an le bar bracelet anti
rapprochement est un dispositif
supplémentaire pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes et dans le
val d'oise le recto premier bilan avec
la rédaction devient 95 sur place une
croix sur les sommets en corse vous
verrez aussi ces images impressionnantes
de l'installation d'une croix en bois
sur l'un des sommets de l'île de beauté
une croix aux fonctions spirituelles et
géographique comme nous l'expliquera à
la rédaction devient telle est pas aisé
sur place la propagande de vichy exposer
et expliquer aux plus jeunes le musée de
la résistance de limoges dévoile des
archives historiques
une exposition non sans lien avec
l'actualité que nous fera découvrir
cette à limoges
je vous le disais dans les titres
l'appel aux dons de l'établissement
français du sang au niveau national le
seuil critique du nombre de poches de
sang en réserve est atteint là où la
france a besoin de 100 mille poches elle
n'en dispose que de 75000 il y a donc
urgence après deux années de tensions
liées à la crise sanitaire le message a
été entendu visiblement à saint-etienne
vous allez le voir un reportage signé
d'anthony vers pillon pour tl7 la
télévision de la loire elle la
quasi-totalité des sièges sont occupés
et les infirmières enchaîne des gestes
rapides mais appliquée la collecte de ce
jeudi midi était assez rythmé à la
maison du don de saint-etienne dans le
quartier de châteaucreux car les
médecins n'ont pas de temps à perdre
avec les poches répertoriés donc là ce
sont des poches qui vont partir en cours
dans ses poches de sang qu'un peu près
dès ce matin à la maison du don et qui
vont partir sur notre service de
préparation études et qui sont prélevés
en même temps les poches sont analysés
demain matin et les profs seront libérés
une fois qu'on aura les résultats donc
là potentiellement elles peuvent aller
sauver des vies à partir de là à partir
de demain après midi et depuis le début
de la semaine les ligériens sont
généreux avec près de 50% de donneurs
supplémentaires sur la seule journée
d'hier c'est important parce que on a
besoin s'en souvenir
les patients et
cet horaire un geste d'autant plus
citoyen que les médecins disent souvent
qu'un seul donneur peut sauver trois
malades car une fois arrivée à l'hôpital
le son est séparé en globules rouges en
plaquettes et en plasma pour réaliser
les transfusions et pour le moment le
seuil d'alerté pointé du doigt par le
ffs n'a pas encore eu d'impact sur les
hôpitaux rappelons tout de même que si
vous avez ulcos vide vous pouvez donner
votre sang quinze jours après les
derniers symptômes et sans restriction
si vous n'êtes qu'à contacter vacciner
le ffs qui appelle tout de même les
donneurs à prendre rendez vous sur le
site qui s'affiche en bas de votre écran
un jeu d'enfant pour certains un
parcours du combattant pour d'autres les
nombreux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ont jusqu'au 4 mars
prochain pour obtenir les fameux 500
parrainages synonyme de leur ticket
d'entrée officielle pour la campagne
alors si les gros candidats ont déjà
leur signature ou sont en passe de le
faire les plus petits peine aujourd'hui
à les réunir un problème démocratique
que tente de régler certains maires des
pays de savoie un reportage de l'uqar
hook pour la rédaction de 8 mont blanc
sur place
la dernière ligne droite est lancé pour
la dizaine de candidats déclarés à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
ils devront obtenir un minimum de 500
parrainages avant le 4 mars prochain
pour officialiser leur candidature cette
quête est d'autant plus compliquée pour
les petits candidats ils sont pour la
plupart moins connu du grand public et
doivent multiplier les interventions
quatre coins de la france pour
convaincre les élus encore incertain le
philosophe gaspard koenig et candidat
déclaré depuis un mois même s'il ne
possède pour l'heure que 27 signature le
candidat garde espoir
ce n'est que depuis mon annonce de
candidature le 11 janvier que très
officiellement si je puis dire je leur
demande le parrainage qui est une
demande toujours un peu humble parce
qu'on fait du démarchage téléphonique
on se présente
et on se prend évidemment beaucoup de
portes dans le nez avant d'en avoir une
qui s'ouvre venus écouter son discours
et doit revenir le maire du petit
village de kate tian interpellé les
nombreuses et du territoire sur la
question du parrainage des
conseils régionaux ou départementaux qui
stresse souvent sur étiqueté
politiquement n'ont aucun problème pour
parrainer leurs candidats de leur
famille politique en règle général les
maires ruraux le plus souvent sont sans
étiquette et finalement c'est le risque
est que les maires à 75% aujourd'hui
dis-je avait parrainé personnes ben
c'est quel mauvais exemple on donne de
son côté antoine valentin le maire de
saint jeoire en faucigny a posté une
vidéo sur internet c'est par le biais de
ses concitoyens que son choix va se
porter au maire et comme élu local mais
j'ai l'habitude de nourrir ma réflexion
de prendre mes décisions en concertation
avec ma population et donc il me
semblait tout naturel de garder le même
mode de fonctionnement pour cents
signatures de parrainage à trois
semaines de la date butoir seuls 6000
parrainages ont été enregistrées par le
conseil constitutionnel sur un peu plus
de 47000 possible
et bruno le maire était l'invité de face
aux territoires jeudi sur tv5monde
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances a notamment évoqué le sujet
crucial de la dette qui s'est creusé
pendant la pandémie regardez cet extrait
de face aux territoires sur tv5 monde
bruno le maire c'est le miz de
l'économie des finances de la relance
une amélioration sur le terrain
sanitaire clair vous vous félicitez d'un
rebond de la croissance il y a des
promesses de dépenses nouvelles chaque
jour dans la campagne présidentielle et
dans son rapport annuel publié hier
pierre moscovici qu'est le premier
président de la cour des comptes parle
d' efforts sans précédent a réalisé il
parle de 9 milliards d'euros d'économies
supplémentaires par an c'est la rigueur
version 1984 qui nous attend juste après
la présidentielle comme par hasard ou
pas oh non je ne crois pas
partage l'appréciation de pierre
moscovici bien entendu qu'il faut
définir ses amis des finances et
détaillant ces derrières s'est bien tenu
mais je pense que simple on prendre un
petit peu de recul sur ce que nous avons
fait et sur ce que nous voulons faire
avec le présent la république nous nous
avons établi des finances publiques
cyril viguier nous sommes revenus sous
les 3% de déficit en 2018 et nous avons
avec cette majorité qui a le
rétablissement des finances publiques
dans son adn nous avons sorti la france
de la procédure pour déficit excessif
ensuite nous avons une crise majeure et
nous avons fait un choix stratégique
avec emmanuel macron qui est de protéger
des salariés et de protéger des
entreprises ce soit là il a été bon
économiquement il a été bon socialement
il était bon politiquement il était bon
aussi pour nos finances publiques parce
que c'est moins cher de protéger que de
réparer les dégâts du chômage et le
dégâts des faillites
il débutera la semaine prochaine le
salon de l'agriculture ouvrira ses
portes le 26 février à paris un rendez
vous incontournable surtout en pleine
année électorale auquel ne pourront pas
participer les agriculteurs martiniquais
en cause les incertitudes liées aux
qu'ovide précision et reportage de jean
marc d'habré pour vient à tv sur place
en martinique
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue
bienvenue au stand martinique du salon
de l'agriculture bienvenue chez nous
venez découvrir notre production nôtre
il s'y voyait déjà
l'animateur habituel du stand martinique
au salon de l'agriculture de paris à
tomber l'événement avec impatience
objectif c'est de pouvoir capter
l'attention des visiteurs et les faire
rester sur leur semble pour qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils soient qu'ils
reparlent plus riches en fait de notre
martinique mais cette année la chambre
d'agriculture de martinique ne sera pas
présente à cet événement incontournable
on permet aussi de rang entre eux
des fois les institutions et donc de
parler de pollution locale soit d'autres
partenaires potentiels notamment sur le
la possibilité certainement chez vous
chez certains production qui peuvent
être intéressants donc ça peut malgré
tout être
un moment en fait deux
les convoyeurs de bizet la filière
banane des antilles elle non plus ne
sera pas représenté une décision motivée
par les risques liées à l'incertitude
générée par la crise sanitaire comme les
passants pas sanitaires et le groupement
les groupes on voulait pas
particulièrement de
la barre près de 350000 euros avaient
été budgétisés pour le salon un
investissement pour faire parler de la
banane et de ses enjeux et qui pourra
être réutilisé sur d'autres événements
d'envergure nationale bon mais on reste
donc sponsors et partenaires sur le
marathon de paris qui va avoir lieu
début du mois d'avril mai puis surtout
on aura effectivement donc le tour de
france ou à l'occasion de cette
prochaine édition et de ceux de ce
partenariat qu'on a renouvelé en 2021
pour les trois prochaines années c'est
la deuxième fois en 15 ans que la
martinique sera absente au salon de
l'agriculture de paris l'année dernière
l'événement ne s'était pas tenue
toujours en raison de la crise sanitaire
c'est un outil de plus dans la
protection des femmes victimes de
violences le bracelet anti rapprochement
est déployé dans toute la france depuis
plus d'un an désormais le système basé
sur une alerte en cas de non respect des
distances par un conjoint ou ex conjoint
violent concerne onze personnes dans le
val d'oise vous allez le voir le
tribunal judiciaire de pontoise a dressé
un bilan du dispositif
la juridiction l'avait déployés en avant
première dans le département michaël
joly provient 95
septembre 2020 le ministre de la justice
eric dupond moretti est au tribunal
judiciaire de pontoise pour lancer un
nouveau dispositif de lutte contre les
violences conjugales le bracelet anti
rapprochement un outil qui a fait ses
preuves en espagne quelques mois plus
tôt cette juridiction à l'avant garde de
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
l'avait réclamé à sa prédécesseure
nicole belloubet un peu plus d'un an
après leur déploiement c'est l'heure du
bilan c'est un dispositif qui est très
précieux pour assurer la protection des
victimes de violences donc le bracelet
anti rapprochement actuellement nous en
avons onze qui sont déployés je rappelle
que le bracelet anti rapprochement est
prononcée par les juges c'est une
décision du juge
alors que le téléphone grave danger il y
en a actuellement 45 qui sont mis à la
disposition du parquet de pontoise le
tgd c'est vraiment un outil qui est à la
disposition des procureurs de la
république et c'est un outil que que
distribue que met en place les
procureurs auprès des victimes qui ont
besoin d'une protection immédiate
complémentaire au téléphone grave danger
le bracelet anti rapprochement consiste
à poser un boîtier électronique
géolocalisé à la chevy d'un conjoint
violent un périmètre autour de la
victime de violence est définie et en
cada proche de celui ci le porteur
reçoit un premier avertissement s'ils
entrent dans le périmètre les forces de
l'ordre sont alertées tout comme la
victime un dispositif parfois difficile
à faire accepter aux victimes il faut
leur accord et beaucoup d'entre elles
sont encore souvent pris ce qui
nécessite une sensibilisation une
intervention des associations de
victimes pour pouvoir accompagner faire
accepter également ce dispositif
lorsqu'il est estimé utile par les
magistrats pour assurer au maximum la
protection de ses victimes l'année
dernière selon le collectif féministe
nous tout 113 femmes sont mortes sous
les coups de leur conjoint ou
ex-conjoint quatre étés valdoisienne
dans le sud ouest un drôle de navire est
en ce moment à l'oeuvre près de
certaines plages du bassin d'arcachon
venus de bretagne une drague propulse le
sable en continu vous allez voir le
dispositif répond à un double objectif
regarnir les zones les plus fragilisées
par le tourisme et les intempéries ainsi
qu'établir un meilleur amortissement des
houles une opération qui durera jusqu'au
28 février et d'un montant de 450 mille
euros les détails au micro de bénédicte
doha de la chaîne du groupe sud ouest tv
7 6 avait pas les opérations de
réensablement sur les plages du pilat
étant donné que c'est difficile d'accès
par des engins mécaniques il y aurait il
y aurait pas du tout de plage à marée
haute et difficilement du sable à marée
basse et on voit qu'au bout de six mois
toutes les communautés benthiques en
fait vient de recoloniser le banc de
sable
à 100 dans le sud ouest tout près de la
frontière espagnole plusieurs maîtres
chiens de la gendarmerie issus de la
chaîne des pyrénées ont participé à un
exercice d'entraînement annuel en haute
garonne ce recyclage opérationnel selon
le jargon utilisé visite à vérifier les
compétences des équipes cynophiles
images et interviews de manon d'aussi
pour la dépêche du midi d'autres
partenaires sur place
travailler avec un chien dans le secours
en l'avalanche le chien ça reste un être
vivant c'est pas une machine qui régler
et qui restent à régler toute l'année
donc il faut s'adapter au travail du
maître au travail du chien et comme on a
des vies qui sont en jeu quand les
personnes sans se vit dans une avalanche
c'est un peu une course contre la montre
donc on se doit d'avoir une équipe
efficace tant au niveau du travail du
chien que du travail du maître avec
l'analyse du terrain la prise de
renseignements et et l'évolution du
secours pendant la recherche
voilà et en cette période de vacances
d'hiver nous ne pouvons que vous
conseiller d'être prudents sur les
pistes et lors de vos balades
non sans lien avec l'environnement dans
les yvelines les collectes arts poursuit
son développement le plus grand campus
agricole au monde accueille désormais
des start up qui évolue dans le domaine
agricole et l'alimentation durable un
écosystème favorable évidemment pour la
recherche un sujet de la rédaction de tv
78 donc dans les yvelines implanté dans
le parc régional naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse hectares présente le
plus grand campus agricoles du monde
créé par audrey bourolleau et xavier
niel et patron de free le centre de
formation a lancé en octobre 2021 son
accélérateur de start up après 135
candidature et 25 présélection 11
entreprises ont été choisies un objectif
commun grandir et évoluer ensemble pour
bâtir l'agriculture de demain on a monté
la première marque d' alternative à la
viande sans ingrédient ultra transformé
donc ça veut dire que base de vrais
ingrédients qu'on pourrait trouver dans
sa cuisine globalement nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à partir du moment où
il récolte son produit jusqu'à la
facturation de ce produit
on intervient sur cette jeune dame
l'accélérateur de start-up s'articule
autour de quatre domaines
l'alimentation l'agriculture
régénératrice lindor farming et la
grille tech qui fait référence à la
robotisation l intelligence artificielle
le kobo tout il aussi la collaboration
entre l'homme et la machine le but c'est
d'avoir de la technologie embarquée qui
soit très sophistiqué mais que l' usage
soit extrêmement simple et donc on a
cherché à faire de cet outil une
plateforme vraiment polyvalente pour que
la personne gagne un maximum de temps
dans le travail et qu'elle puisse
l'utiliser à beaucoup d' usage différent
donc du semis à la plantation au
désherbage à la récolte les onze
start-up vont bénéficier du double
réseau hec paris et hectares soit 30
mentor et 500 experts elles vont
également pouvoir profiter d'un espace
de travail de 2000 m² ainsi que de 50 ha
d'expérimentation je trouve qu'ils sont
un réseau non seulement de mentors qui
peuvent nous accompagner nous aider à
dire passer à l'échelle et atteindre ses
2500 twitter à la fin de l'année le
partage d'un réseau mais aussi des mêmes
valeurs autour de l'environnement et le
souhait d'une agriculture plus durable
c'est génial parce que ha bien
rassembler des gens avec des compétences
extrêmement fortes dans le domaine de
l'agroalimentaire
les mette autour de la table pour
partager une vision commune de
l'agriculture durable l'accélérateur a
pour objectif final de permettre le
développement de 80 start up en deux ans
dans le secteur agricole
une belle histoire à présent dans ce
grand gîte et des territoires celle de
gilles le druillennec qui sensibilise
les jeunes au handicap
l'artiste infirme moteur et cérébrale de
naissance se raconte avec beaucoup
d'humour dans un spectacle qui ouvre le
dialogue ensuite avec son public près du
mans il s'est rendu dans un collège et
hélène galiana pour lm tv sarthe à
assister à cette belle rencontre
regardez
jusqu'à très correct et moi je serais
moi et il l'a fait gilles le druillennec
est le seul moniteur de voile handicapés
de france il est venu ce vendredi
raconté son histoire devant une centaine
de sixième
l'amplitude des textes de changer le
regard c'est que au départ continue des
cours sauf m il ya quelques handicapés
pour qu'il soit pacifique handicap
mental ou auteurs ou donc je raconte
pour un parcours au fur et à mesure mon
histoire il rentre dans ma vie et
découvre que alan que moi plus conduire
puisque brevet d'état papa car pendant
deux heures gilles et sa femme agnès
aborde avec humour et sans tabou la vie
de l'homme de 59 ans il demande aux
élèves de participer en incarnant
différents personnages
c'est le livre des records et il nous
faut mieux les choses et quand je dis on
croise un après où deux ans après ça
reste de mémoriser est-ce que s'il
faisait une conférence ça sans faire de
jeu et bien une conférence toulon 8 fort
que là je vous trouve des enfants qui
grandissent et qui me reconnaît il va
tout ce qui est à tout ce qui nous est
dit c'est resté gravé en moi et le
message semble passer il faut pas
comparer les personnes handicapées à
nous ils sont comme nous c'est juste ils
ont un petit problème
lundi café basse est différente des
autres essaient de faire des espèces moi
je suis dyslexique aussi nom du coup je
suis j'ai un handicap mais mon coin je
sais qu'on peut aller jusqu'au bout de
ses rêves c'est important que les jeunes
soient sensibilisés on vit dans une
société qui est pas toujours facile
et du coup qui n'ont pas forcément
toujours des belles choses nous c'est
important de leur montrer que bah oui on
peut avoir un handicap et réussir dans
la vie faire des belles choses et gilles
est quand même un personnage assez
particulier qui est touchant et ça ça
devient vite vite une mascotte un
spectacle où les enfants découvrent
comment la différence peut devenir une
force le tout compte et par les héros
d'une belle histoire d'amour
[Musique]
des images impressionnantes et tout en
hauteur dans ce journal maintenant elles
viennent de corse entre l'île rousse et
calvi le mont saints-anges qui culmine à
562 m c'est habillée cette semaine d'une
nouvelle croix sommitale une imposante
croix en bois pour délimiter les
frontières entre deux communes une
opération rare autant spirituel que
géographique et sportive raconté au
micro de franco farce et y ait de jean
colonna de viable télé pas aisé sur
place on peut s'apercevoir que dans tous
les sommets de corse il ya une croix et
moi j'ai demandé un petit peu à nos
anciens issus du côté de cas la gauche
j'ai demandé pourquoi une croix à un
roman répondu peut-être c'est vrai c'est
pas vrai je sais rien mais on me disait
que la première des choses c'était la
croyance encore ça et c'était une
délimitation des territoires quand il
passait avec les troupeaux
l'installation de cette croix
aujourd'hui quand même symbolique parce
que on voit toute la jeunesse qui est là
aujourd'hui la jeunesse et d'autres hein
mais c'est très important parce que je
le répète ce site est symbolique avec un
village de chaque côté un couvent de
chaque côté donc c'était très importante
que la commune aujourd'hui se
représenter lors de cette manifestation
au pays de redon à mi chemin entre
rennes et nantes les maisons éclusières
vont bientôt connaître une nouvelle vie
c'est en tout cas le souhait des
collectivités bretonnes qui viennent de
lancer un appel à projet pour
transformer quatre de ces maisons
actuellement inoccupés l'objectif
proposer des activités touristiques dans
un cadre bucolique
un reportage de claire viallon pour tvr
à rennes
à saint-vincent-sur-oust sur les bords
du canal de nantes à brest la maison
éclusière attend sa métamorphose
alors nous voici devant les cluses de la
mcl et et devant cette maison éclusière
donc c'est une des trois maisons
propriété de la région bretagne que l'on
souhaite mettre à disposition de tous
porteurs de projets redon agglomération
et la région bretagne propose de
transformer les 80 mètres carrés le but
de cet appel à projets apporter de
nouvelles activités dont quatre maisons
situées le long du chemin de halage
l'idée c'est de structurer et de
structurer ce touriste d'apporter du
service du service aux randonneurs
chacun a besoin de regonfler son vélo de
pouvoir se nourrir ses vergers trouver
un pique nique
guinguette location de vélos ou
hébergement toutes les idées sont les
bienvenues à avessac par exemple le gîte
d'étape aimerait bien compléter son
offre au bord de l'eau ce bâtiment a une
plaie stratégiques plats nous avons la
vilaine
et nous sommes sur le chemin
de cyclotouristes l'avait 42 qui y va
donc de redon à rennes jusqu'à
saint-malo de quoi laisser libre cours à
son imagination car c'est bien les
candidats retenus qui devront effectuer
les travaux d'aménagement région
bretagne les mets en clos couvert c'est
à dire l'huisserie menuiserie toiture
prête en fait la coque extérieure et à
charge de chaque porteur de projet
d'aménager l'intérieur à ses frais
depuis le début de l'appel à projets 60
dossiers ont déjà été demandés fin des
candidatures le 29 août prochain
après le sculpteur sur pierre le
joaillier le ferronnier et bien d'autres
encore la poste vient de lancer un
nouveau timbre dans sa série consacrée
aux métiers d'art mise à l'honneur cette
fois ci l'activité de luthiers et bien
sûr quand on évoque les fabricants
d'instruments à cordes on pense aussi à
la commune de mirecourt capitale de la
lutherie c'est dans cette ville
logiquement que la poste a présenté ses
nouveaux timbres aux collectionneurs ils
étaient nombreux pour l'occasion image
et réactions recueillies par anthony sa
de vosges télévision
je suis collectionneur ça fait une
quarantaine d'années à peu près
l'amour des timbres avec l'état branleur
prend les tas de choses l'histoire la
géo la lutherie un événement à mirecourt
et lynch est une passion ça permet donc
au club philatélique de participer et
puis à tous les collectionneurs de gérer
de d'améliorer et de continuer leur leur
propre collection quoi et puis surtout
c'est de ces deux données d'un zoom non
seulement sur la ville mais c'est
surtout sur sur la lutherie
direction limoges maintenant pour
terminer ce grand jt des territoires le
musée de la résistance de la ville
propose en ce moment une exposition pour
comprendre et pour éclairer les rouages
de la propagande de vichy auprès des
jeunes vénération du chef de l'état
valeurs morales regroupés autour du
travail de la famille de la patrie cette
exposition pédagogique et historique
résonne avec l'actualité à quelques
semaines de l'élection présidentielle
un sujet d'alain druot pour 7 à limoges
questionner l'histoire de notre pays y
compris durant les heures sombres de la
deuxième guerre mondiale est dans l'adn
du musée de la résistance qui programme
jusqu'à la fin de l'été une exposition
pédagogique vichy parle aux jeunes
français d'une exposition vraiment qui
s'adresse au jeune public qui a été
conçue vraiment pour un public à partir
de l'âge de 10 ans travailler avec des
collégiens des lycéens mais qui est
ouverte à tout public lorsque les
visiteurs viennent au musée le titre n'a
pas été choisi au hasard voilà donc
c'est vraiment ciblé sur sur cette jeune
quand on arrive dans une exposition en
fait on se retrouve face à face avec une
affiche qui a été très très célèbre
pendant pendant cette période des années
40 évidemment c'est le portrait de
philippe pétain avec le nouveau slogan à
cette époque là qui était donc
révolution nationale ce qu'il faut le
rappeler évidemment philippe pétain donc
la suite de la signature donc de
l'armistice en juin 1940 va obtenir
quelques semaines après ce qu'on a
appelé les pleins pouvoirs fil de
l'exposition les mécanismes de la
communication de vichy sont assis
expliquer la valeur scientifique de
cette présentation visuelle et
didactique est grande et puisque
désormais l'histoire est régulièrement
convoqué autant pouvoir faire la part du
vrai et de la propagande que semaine
évidemment de de ce grand moment
électorale voilà il ya plein de
parallèles à faire et s'est montré aussi
voilà plein de choses par rapport aux 6
à la société comme le musée la
résistance n'est pas que ce qui s'est
passé en 1940
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi sur
vos chaînes locales de la tnt sur
tv5monde et sur lcp on se retrouve très
vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous
[Musique]